bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne les travaux de la
délégation sénatoriale à l'outre-mer
elle a auditionné la semaine dernière le
ministre victorin lurel sur la question
de l'octroi de mer ce dispositif qui
constitue une ressource importante pour
l'autre mère d'un montant de plus d'un
milliard d'euros arrive à son terme en
juin 2014
le ministre a donc fait part aux
sénateurs de ces propositions qu'il doit
faire à l'union européenne pour
pérenniser ce dispositif
retour donc cet après midi sur cette
audition bonne après midi à tous très
bien mes chers collègues nous concevons
de travaux nous avons le bonheur plaisir
d'accueillir nouvelle fois monsieur le
président monsieur le sénat sur ce
président est monsieur be nice nous
avons eu l'occasion de recevoir
d'ailleurs après son installation au
ministère le 11 juillet dernier
depuis lors l'actualité des outre-mer
été chargé des dossiers traités par
obligation se sont multipliés ceux ci
ont donné l'occasion par deux fois de
débat en présence que ce ministre dans
l'hémicycle 12 juillet 2012 avec un
débat organisé sous la base de quoi ppr
e relatives à la prise en compte des
réalités ultramarines par l'union
européenne dans la réforme de la
politique commune de la pêche dont il
parlait à quelques instants le 19
novembre dernier
ppr sur la stratégie européenne pour les
régions a péri dans le nouveau cadre
financier pluriannuel un nouveau sujet
européenne nous préoccupe aujourd'hui le
renouvellement du régime fiscal
dérogatoire applicables aux roms dans
les départements d'outre-mer et de
souhaite une nouvelle fois puis et
démarche du gouvernement auprès des
instances bruxelloises notamment de la
commission européenne il s'agit d'un
dossier épineux non dénué de risques
contentieux est placée sous le signe de
l'urgence puisque le vip ce régime en
vigueur vient à expiration en fin
d'année 2013
autres sujets européens suspens le
première il s'agit là aussi d'une
question cruciale notamment pour les
budgets de nos collectivités et alors
même que cet aspect cette approche est
étrangère à la commission européenne une
gardienne du principe de libre échange
de libre concurrence qu'elle soit
monsieur le ministre les perspectives
européennes pour le poids de mr le guen
mathilde était en définitive en mesure
de fournir les justificatifs demandés
par bruxelles
je crois savoir monsieur disent que vous
avez rencontré les autorités européennes
sur tous ces sujets le 13 bardet a nié
et de pouvoir nous donner des nouvelles
des nouvelles fraîches penseurs bonne
qui skie sur la nature ou des spas à
apaiser nos inquiétudes
autre sujet brûlant pour nos écrans
ultra marines l'avenir des dispositifs
de défiscalisation des investissements
réalisés outre-mer
il y a bien sûr à définir la réponse
technique permettant de traduire la
promesse faite par le président la
république de neutraliser financièrement
parlant pour 2013 validation de la part
variable du plafond résultant la
décision du conseil constitutionnel
qu en est il et quand la mission confiée
à madame boullier aboutira-t-elle mais
au-delà de cette préoccupation de court
terme puisqu'elle ne concerne que
l'année 2013
il convient dans un contexte budgétaire
de plus en plus contraints de se
préoccuper des perspectives de poux 2014
c'est pourquoi et comme j'ai pu vous
l'annoncer il ya plusieurs semaines
monsieur le ministre
notre délégation a souhaité un rien ou
de travail commun avec la commission des
affaires économiques dont le président
el hadj daoud aujourd'hui procéder à une
évaluation de l'impact de ces
dispositifs fiscaux en vigueur sur les
économies de la marine et nous sommes en
effet qu'il faut en amont de la
recherche d'éventuels mécanismes
alternatifs mesurer la portée économique
des dispositifs en place cette démarche
cette démarche d'évaluation doit venir
compléter l'approché habituelle qui nous
paraît trop exclusivement financière
on a donc trois sujets importants sur
lesquels nous souhaitons vous entendre
monsieur le ministre le débat qui suivra
vos interventions de conduire a
certainement aborder bien d'autres
questions de la limite de votre
disponibilité bien sûr mais nous avons
réservé deux heures pour travailler avec
vous monsieur x pour moi dit nous sommes
prêts à travail je suis donc la parole
je te président merci merci
la délégation de m'accueillir une fois
de plus merci à vous sénatrices et
sénateurs de m'accueillir pour une
petite séance de travail
monsieur le président vous avez abordé
sur 903 question moi si je me suis
trompé
la fiscalité du rhum l'emploi
défiscalisation et l'apaisement
donc on va voir ma pêche d'abord
permettez moi de faire un petit point
sur le cadre financier pluriannuel
2014-2020
pour ce qui concerne le sort si j'ose
dire réservé aux régions
ultrapériphériques et en particulier les
françaises et les ultra périphériques
française mais entendu en y incluant
mayotte qui sera rude à compter du 1er
janvier 2014 où le budget alloué à la
politique de cohésion est en baisse on
le sait de 8,5 pour cent mais les
lésions périphériques
d'autres verts en tout cas les
françaises les rubans générales
bénéficieront d'une enveloppe en légère
progression en euros constants alors
l'intensité dead on le sait pour
l'allocation spécifique pour les rup
sera certes en diminution
on l'a su on a fait l'objet de
discussions âpres sur la prochaine
période de moins 130 millions en euros
constants au moins 75 millions en euros
courants alors euros constants de
l'année 2011
mais la diminution de l'allocation
spéciale rude devrait être plus que
compensé par l'augmentation de
l'enveloppé recevront les rup au titre
de la catégorie des régions les moins
développées soit plus 171 millions euros
constants 2011 ou plus 16,198 millions
en euros courants
donc première compensation deuxième si
j'ose dire compensation c'est le
bénéfice que les rues pourront retirer
de l'initiative pour l'emploi des jeunes
qui sont fonds destiné à abonder
l'enveloppent de cohésion pour les
régions frappées par un chômage des
jeunes élevé
alors aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire de
manière très précise quel sera le
montant précis de l'envelope dont
bénéficieront les régions d'outre-mer
pour 7
allocation cette initiative pour
l'emploi des jeunes mais on peut
j'espère ne pas me tromper on estime sur
la base des données de 2011 des taux de
chômage 2011 même s'il ya un problème
sur mayotte
je dois revoir les enquêtes et les
recensements la france pourrait
bénéficier
je ne veux pas dire te ferait bénéficier
de quelque 214 millions d'euros en
grande partie au profit de nos régions
d'outre-mer dont les taux de chômage des
jeunes
on le sait sont plus élevés qu'en
métropole donc au total les quatre
routes françaises
or mayotte devraient bénéficier de 3,3
milliards d'euros pour la période 2014
2020 contre 2,7 milliards d'euros sur
l'ancienne période 2007 2013 ce sont des
chiffres en euros constants qu'il
convient de prendre avec précaution mais
ça donne une un ordre de grandeur soit
une hausse de 598 millions d'euros
l'enveloppé globale allouée aux rudes
français devrait donc avoisiner les 3
milliards 7 dans le prochain cadre
financier pluriannuel compte 3 milliards
2 en 2007 2013 soit une hausse de 16%
donc en comptant l'initiative jeu pour
mayotte
il ya là souci on a une enveloppe
forfaitaire de 200 millions au titre de
la politique de cohésion est à dire
feder et fse
cette enveloppe représente dix fois plus
que le montant actuel alloués par
l'union européenne à mayotte au titre du
faible mais il est vrai que le montant
octroyé est en recul par rapport aux
estimations initiales
il faut qu'on le dise ce qui nourrit à
mayotte une certaine déception alors
discussions de ce qu'on attendait à peu
près 450 millions il faut il faut se le
dire
ces 200 millions le constituent que la
part au titre de la politique de
cohésion
viendront s'ajouter aux cofinancements
les contreparties nationales et privées
cette approche devrait également abondé
être abondée par l'initiative pour
l'emploi des jeunes font comme jeudi
dédiée aux régions souffrent d'un taux
de chômage élevé des jeunes
il n'est pas encore possible et c'est là
que nous avons un petit doute il faut
attendre des précisions
les enquêtes supplémentaires par l'insee
pas encore possible établi de manière
exacte l'enveloppent dont bénéficiera
mayotte aussi de cette initiative car
les chiffres notre disposition sont des
chiffres je crois de 2011 les sites de
2012 ne sont pas disponibles
et si ce sont des sites de 2011 on
risque d'avoir un soutien serait en deçà
légèrement de sa du seuil
donc on a commandé d'autres enquêtes
le conseil européen prévu une clause de
réexamen c'est ça qui peut être
intéressant 2016 au timbre à kehl sur la
base des données statistiques les plus
récentes des ajustements dans veloppe
pourront intervenir
il importe dès lors que le territoire
soit en capacité de consommer ces
crédits selon des procédures régulières
inégal au regard du droit européen sur
des projets structurants le
développement de l'île ça veut dire il
nous faut consommer des 200 millions si
on arrivait à les consommer à un bon
grip en 2016 on peut on valorise et les
montants octroyés les 200 millions
pourrait se rapprocher je l'espère des
400 à 450 millions
je rappelle que cette enveloppe mais que
le palais contribution de l'union
européenne au titre du posei donc le
premier pilier de la pac du fait à dr et
du fesf le fonds européen pour les
affaires maritimes
et la pêche pour je finis la sur ce
petit point d'information pour les p t
om des pays et territoires d'outre-mer
la situation je l'avouer un peu plus
difficile la présidence propose de doter
les p t om un budget de vous le savez de
305,7 millions d'euros sur la période
2014 2020 contre 343 2 7 millions
d'euros initialement proposé par la
commission dans sa communication de juin
2011 soit une diminution par rapport au
10ème fed en l'état en euros courants et
à périmètre et à calendrier comparable
donc sur ces temps et à mayotte pour les
p&t sommes quittés péter om pour
intégrer les rup l'enveloppa cp croît de
11 9% alors que s&p quoi le 11,9 pour
cent et celle des p t om diminue de 0,4
pour cent pour la france est un peu
difficile
elle a déjà exprimé son souhait de voir
rétabli l'enveloppent dpt om au niveau
initialement proposée soit 340 3 7
millions estimant qu'il n'était pas
possible d'afficher une baisse de
notation pour les p t om alors même que
les pays
a cp voyez quattre leur dotation de près
de 11% à 12%
je propose surfaceuse avait tellement
les chiffres déluge de chiffres en
quelque sorte
je pense que les éclairs et parce que
vous avez compris ce n'est pas du
bonneteau du genre l'avion n'a pas vu
c'est si je reprends la substance les
nouvelles sont bonnes sorte pour mayotte
qui peut être une petite déception
ses beaux-parents et peuple et péter om
pour les bété om oui mon faudrait un
petit peu en retrait mais il ya un hic
études bon on sait que le budget
européen n'a pas été voté et la question
des subventions auxquelles aussies
brazza bas ça peut arriver que les
débutés open ne vote pas le budget qu
est ce qui se passe autour
avouer j'ai l'impression qu'on
fonctionne sur les douzièmes provisoires
aujourd'hui et je peux vous dire dans
les régions et en particulier dans les
régions d'outremer il ya là un véritable
sujet et je pèse mes mots
depuis déjà un temps il y une suspension
des versements vous me direz si je me
trompe
notamment sur le fait des relais fait se
rassurent la plupart des fonds il ya une
vraie crise de trésorerie
au point que les préfets sont prêts à
demander aux banques peuvent faire les
avances sur des crédits engagés et sur
des opérations parfois déjà réalisé et
il n'y a plus de crédit pour de deux
nouveaux projets avant la fin de cette
année 2013 avec vous le savez
obligations de paiement jusqu'en 2015 il
ya une vraie crise alors si un autre
sens le parlement ne devez pas à voter
en plusieurs comprendre que le parlement
en tout cas le son président demandait
quelques arriérés à la commission et que
ces quelques milliards je crois que ces
16 milliards 17 milliards d'euros
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
pardonnez moi d'être un peu simple donc
il ya là un vrai souci autant on s'est
quand même des gens le bien défendu et
en particulier dans la défense de la pac
si le président se fait persister sauf à
trouver des accords vont monter le
budget on aura quelques
souci on l'a déjà on l'aurait sur sur
l'avenir sauf mais là on quitterait le
cas de cette délégation a changé
totalement de la politique européenne et
à passer à une activation encore plus
dynamique de la politique monétaire
c'est à dire de la banque centrale
européenne qui pourrait financer
autrement la dette souveraine avec des
taux plus faibles qui nous donnerait des
marges de manoeuvre sur la croissance
mais ça c'est de la macro économie
européenne
initiative cours donnés de croissance
qui permettrait peut-être au niveau
international et demain dans le j-20 de
trouver avec les états unis
quelques accords et peut-être violé ce
faire la chine mais je me permets de
dire tant que l'élection allemande n'est
pas passée on aura du mal à obtenir tout
cela non mais il ya pile existe pas dans
le cas où vous payez un dispositif
similaire à ce qui existe aux etats unis
quand on vote parce qu'on ne parle vous
ne vous êtes pas il y à conduction
collection de l'ancien dirigeant
il fonctionne je viens
en termes comptables sous les douzièmes
provisoires sur la base de l'ancien
budget ne sera pas durer c'est comme
dans les collectivités
lorsque votre budget n'est pas voté vous
avez des règles pour engager des crédits
de fonctionnement douzièmes provisoires
et vous avez une délibération qui est
demandée pour engager je crois qu'à des
dépenses et d'investissements rydia
j'allais dire quelque chose qui me
coûtera cher c'était riespach booth 6
tonnes thibout est bien la même chose
existe
c'était dans notre hémisphère que la
phrase a été pas comprise issue mais tu
as disputé en disons cela comme ça qui
permet d'assurer le quotidien mais je
peux vous dire la crise est déjà là il
ya une crise de trésorerie dans l'été
c'est vrai pour la métropole mais c'est
vrai encore plus dans les régions
d'outremer on a pas de mécanisme de
préfinancement ce qui est donc premier
problème deuxième problème lorsque s'est
engagée
mieux encore payé et bien les crédits
européens ne sont pas les mêmes les
créances avéré c'est à dire qu'ils ne
font pas l'objet de contestation par la
cic c'est l'organe de contrôle
et puis il ya la grèce ou silva la crise
et donc c'est ça devait durer et si le
parlement qui peut-être d'ailleurs très
qui peut améliorer une épure et un
projet est bien devait persister et
l'europe restait sans budget pendant
longtemps on a quelques soucis mais bon
si le bien est ce que je fais pas ça
partout j'étais à mon collègue patients
juste une petite petite interrogation de
précisions je me suis laissé dire que
par les esprits certainement que les
faux de cohésion représentait
anciennement 33 euros par tête
d'habitant pour les routes et que après
la nouvelle mouture de presser 703 euros
seront certes ce n est due à 30 euros
c'était un euro c'était dans les
propositions de l'aco
le sens était bien au fait ou payants
glace et de 35 euros à 20 euros et
l'amélioration sait aujourd'hui combien
30,30 euros 30 juin mais on avait perdu
sa bien sûr mais c'était tout qu'un
second vers des plus grands la
discussion on a moins bien on a moins
perdu mais il faut le dire les choses
sont compliquées mais faisons difficile
il faut pas se faire beaucoup
d'illusions 7 discussions âpres et on a
vu les positions des uns et des autres
bon finalement sans vouloir faire dans
le dithyrambe la france s'est bien
débrouillé dans la sphère le 6 il faut
continuer à se battre pour améliorer les
enveloppes et nous-mêmes pour consommer
ces enveloppes là on est pour mayotte
voir si à la révision à mi parcours on
pourrait améliorer les choses ça veut
dire qu'il nous faut mettre au point un
dispositif organisationnel une
assistance technique qui permet de
préparer les dossiers les consommer les
contrôler et les à l'idée bon voilà
d'autant plus que disons le clairement
mayotte va subir un choc considérable
c'est pas simplement la rupéïsation mais
c'est aussi le fait que dès le 1er
janvier 2014
en tout cas en théorie et on s'y prépare
your application du code général des
impôts et donc pour cela il ya l'acte
iii de la décentralisation qui va
confier la gestion des fonds européens
aux régions mais pour ça il ya une sorte
de petite clause qui dit il faut moins
que la santé financière de la
collectivité ne voit pas en cause ça
veut dire que donc au préalable il faut
des plans de redressement
d'assainissement de modernisation de
de l'organisation bon c'est un très très
gros travail qu'il faudra faire d'autant
plus que pour éviter qu'une règle ne
s'applique de la même manière et un peu
partout dont on est partis turretot puis
on va probablement laisser ça la
discrétion des élus et des élites qui
demanderont soins le transfert soit la
délégation si c'est un transfert en
pleine digestion
lorsqu il y à des remboursements opérés
ça peut ruiner une collectivité
il faut donc quelque part selon un
équilibre à trouver dans le texte que
l'état reste présent au kazoo et donc
les élus seront donc responsabiliser ne
le sont déjà
ils le seront davantage lorsqu ils
demanderont en connaissance le transfert
télé d'hier clé entier de ce domaine de
compétence mais il faudra le mont venus
se tuent faut pas souhaité assumer
toutes les conséquences
bon voilà donc mayotte la vie un choc de
départementalisation régionalisation et
de rupéïsation qu'il faut préparer ce
que nous faisons ça demande la
mobilisation dont inattendue de tous
alors sur la fiscalité du rhum est à une
seconde question de georges patient être
à travers les chiffes qui a été annoncé
il ya une progression
mais ce qu'on a déjà une idée de la
ventilation entre les différents fonds
et quels sont les thèmes qui ont été
retenus sur la pop le jour
est ce qu'on peut avoir l'idée sur la
ventilation entre les différents fonds
et sur les thèmes qui ont été retenus
dans nos bases encore non parce qu'on
sait que notre également vos problèmes
non est-ce que mayotte ni xavier bron
utiliser les fonds pour rattraper un
certain retard infrastructurel je ne
sais pas toi je peux pas et l'azuré
temps je n'ai pas encore c'est que ces
informations
je n'ai pas fait à ma connaissance je ne
lis pas encore très bien
- béthanie oui oui mais ce ministre vous
avez parlé d'eux mais le micro ce n'est
pas la question comment faire pour que
demain il n'y ait pas encore une plus
grande déception et notamment ne pas
louper le virage de 2016 ou un plan de
rattrapage c'est comme ça que je le vois
est possible mais sous réserve de
consommation des 200 millions d'ores et
déjà attribués et vous avez
effectivement poser les choses des défis
énormes atteindre le 101e département
des défis qui renvoie directement à
l'état des collectivités qui sont dans
une maladie chronique depuis depuis
toujours j'ai envie de dire et c'est
pour ça que je compte sur vous monsieur
le ministre pour faire cet
accompagnement notamment accompagnement
en ingénierie qui n'a jamais eu lieu
qui n'a jamais eu lieu depuis 2004 parce
que lorsque nous parlons de
décentralisation en droit commun nous
nous référons à 1982 mais pour mayotte
c'est 2004 une décentralisation qui n'a
été accompagnée de quasiment aucun aucun
moyen donc pour autant il ya eu des
transferts de de compétences mais sans
forcément de de transfert de moyens donc
à un moment il va falloir se poser et il
n'est jamais trop tard pour bien faire
pour opérer ce transfert et quand je
parle de transfert c'est surtout de
compétences d'ingénierie qui n'a jamais
eu lieu dans l'histoire de ce
département
et ce alors même que nous allons vous
l'avez dit vers ces rendez vous mais ces
rendez-vous monumentaux trois
rendez-vous d'une importance capitale la
rupéïsation la fiscalité
là le donc la rupéïsation la fiscalité
et l'acte iii de la décentralisation
tous ces rendez vous vont avoir lieu en
même temps
et si aucun effort
si rien de nouveau n'est fait pour
préparer les collectivités à consommer
européen et bien même ces 200 millions
ne seront ne le seront pas et c'est sur
ce point là que je voulais insister mois
sur la polémique
c'est une satisfaction c'est une
déception non c'est pas ce n'est pas la
question
effectivement 200 millions si ils ne
sont pas consommés eh bien ça ne
ça ne rime à rien pour faire en sorte
qu'il le soit parce que les problèmes
sont majeurs les difficultés socio
économiques sont sans précédent et faire
en sorte que non seulement ces 200
millions soit consommée mais également à
ne pas rater le virage de 2016 et pour
ça les collectivités ont besoin d'être
accompagnés pour acquérir petit à petit
de l'ingénierie pour au final est bien
méritée vraiment de de consommer dans le
cadre de la décentralisation très bien
ses ministres monsieur le sénateur je
vous remercie de votre modération et de
votre compréhension
parce que j'entends vos les élus de
mayotte et je lis la presse de mayotte
c'est d'abord la déception qui a prévalu
et c'est ce qui se laisse entendre et
lire je vous remercie de comprendre les
choses j'ai dit de manière peu et
l'éthique et rapide que c'est dix fois
plus que le le
le fait on a eu du mal jusqu'à
maintenant consommée le fait qu'ils
étaient de 11 millions 23 millions au
total
bon là il ya 200 millions à consommer
l'état si j'avais une petite amodiations
à faire sur ce que vous disiez il ya eu
des transferts de compétences y avait
aussi des transferts le moyen toutes les
collectivités effectivement disent qu'il
faut encore plus de moyens face aux
charges transférées à mayotte i il y en
a eu il ya 3000 employés au conseil
général le président gillot et président
de conseil général
quatre cent mille habitants y'a pas toi
1000 employés c'est ces deux fois et
demie plus prescott que le conseil
général de la guadeloupe
bon on a de vrais soucis à mayotte
notamment sur l'aide sociale à l'enfance
la zone je veux bien qu'on ne prenne
comme pendant les mois de juillet ça
comme justificatif de paddy comme
prétexte que c'est des enfants est en
déshérence
non il ya des enfants de mayotte et qui
ont besoin de la protection judiciaire
elles ont besoin de protection d'être
social donc on l'a en vrai sujet pour
aujourd'hui demain et après demain haut
de la butte de choc voire détroit shock
évoquée vous avez vous aurez quand même
des recettes complémentaires importante
que vous aurez à gérer
vous aurez donc toi demain vous aurez
l'octroi de mer non mais qui ce sont des
recettes
ce sont des recettes et qui seront très
très importante c'est un vrai choc
et contrairement à ce que l'on croit
vous ne serez pas en pénurie
il faudra donc là au delà de ce que
l'état fera puisque on a mis en place un
comité de pilotage
on a dégagé 2 millions pour former des
agents aux fonds européens à la gestion
très concret très pratique et
pragmatique de la gestion des fonds
européens l'état est déjà là mais il
faudra donc tous ensemble la
collectivité majeur qui est le
département les communes le syndicat
mixe le smiam pour ce qui concerne les
équipements scolaires
bref il faudra là un coup de collier
pour faire face à cet afflux d'argent
c'est jeudi renouveau et donc il faudra
donc une organisation des compétences
des cadres pour gérer tout ça moi je ne
suis pas déçu je et simplement les gens
ne comprennent pas qu'il y aura beaucoup
de choses à gérer qui aura beaucoup de
recettes à gérer avec qu'en face il
faudra bien une organisation appropriée
et donc c'est ce que nous chercherons à
faire avec vous voilà c'est tout de
suite le promettait du rhum je voudrais
avant toute chose vous présenter deux
rapporteurs sur la peau la ppr home si
son agir à césar voilà deux voies c'est
un signe gillot
voilà vous êtes tout de suite apparu sur
le forum je me suis rendu récemment à
bruxelles pour tenter et pour plaider
cette affaire là vous savez quel est le
régime actuel durant son régime
en termes de définition son régime
en terme de fiscalité et son régime un
terme disons comté jean terre ce qui
nous préoccupe c'est là la fiscalité
aujourd'hui le rom paye des bois
d'assises dans le cadre d'un contingent
annuel de 120 mille hectolitres d'alcool
pur
sur autorisation décision de la
commission qui prendra fin au 31
décembre 2013
alors aujourd'hui l'europe et 859 euros
des toiles et alcool pur gt 2011 pardon
des autres alcools 1514
donc il ya un différentiel de 42% soit
655 euros dans le col de manse une
raison ce sera des chiffres plus la
vignette de sécurité sociale payée qui
était de 160 euros détecte les d'alcool
pur
la chose a changé en volume bardon
actuelle on voyait pas en quoi c'est une
différence
une subtilité mais qui a toute son
importance après ce régime a été
sensiblement modifiée lors du vote de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale en 2012 et de la loi de finances
rectificative de 2012 nouveau régime qui
fait que l'état pays beaucoup plus
subventionne beaucoup plus de 66
millions en 2011 on passait à 111
millions à compter du 1er janvier 2012
le régime au titre de 2012 ont droit de
finances rectificative 2009 était le
suivant random taux d'acides 903 euros
les autres roms 1660 euros
l'avenir de sécurité sociale pour le
rhum des dom 361 euros aux 3 533 euros
total 1200 64 euros pour le rôle des
deux hommes et pour les autres 2193 soit
un différentiel de fiscalité toujours de
42% représentante 929 euros hectolitres
d'alcool pur
tout cela fait une aide d'état de 111
millions depuis janvier 2012 cette
mesure est entrée en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2012 elle n'a jamais été
notifiées et accepter au préalable par
la dg concurrence
sitôt arrivé j'ai procédé la
notification ça c'est fait le 7 août
j'ai eu des échanges avec la dg taxud et
la belgique ont deux
commissaire ils sont assez étonné par ce
là donc on risque d'être de nous
reprocher de surcompensé l'a fait en
plus du cartel illégal du régime de nous
reprocher d'avant surcompensé la filière
sans justifier les coûts à due
proportion et d'autre part donc d'avoir
mis en place un régime illégal car non
déclarés pour trouver une solution
acceptable à la fois par la filière pour
préserver son équilibre et par bruxelles
pour ne pas nous mettre en infraction à
au regard des règles de la concurrence
là il convient et c'est la proposition
qui a été faite de faire évoluer le
régime plusieurs choses ont été prises
en compte plus je postule à on peut dire
ça comme ça
le maintien d'un différentiel de
taxation des roms des dom au regard des
autres alcools du même segment
commercial
on est d'accord sur ce principe là il
faut souligner à cet égard que les roms
des pays tiers notamment je suis bacardi
et dia géo bénéficie de soutien connexes
est extrêmement élevé du gouvernement
américain donc là il n'hésite pas
deuxième principe la compétitivité de la
filière le maintien de l'emploi c'est
quand même plus de 20000 emplois directs
et indirects
la préservation troisième principe de
l'équilibré économique des petites
distillerie qui dans la production plus
tourné vers les roms à très fort degré
alcoolique mécaniquement plus touchées
par une fiscalité calculée sur le litre
d'alcool pur pas en volume
quand c'est en en alcool pur qu'ils sont
elles sont plus pénalisées sans
régularisation rapide nous nous exposons
de la part de la commission européenne à
l'inscription de la mesure au registre
des aides illégales et hors versements
des aides versées illégalement depuis le
1er janvier 2012 après plusieurs
réunions interministérielles
on a proposé la commission
de modifier le régime selon les
paramètres suivants suppression du
mécanisme de plafonnement de la vigne de
sécurité sociale en contrepartie afin de
rétablir le même différentiel des deux
camps 2011 diminution du taux d'accises
sur les roms des dom la région de 50% du
taux normal ce qui est permis par
l'actuel décision de la commission est
un mécanisme haddock dérogatoires pour
les petite distillerie dont calcul de la
vignette non sur le litre d'alcool pur
qui pénalise comme je le disais les
romains degré alcoolique élevées mais
sur le litre volume alors ça donne le
tableau suivant en montant maximal
différentiel de d'assises à raison de 50
% du plafond
ce serait désormais pour les dom 844
euros
52e et non plus 9 103 pour les autres
rome 1600 89,05 pour la vignette et bien
ce serait la même chose pour tous les
roms rome d'hommes 533 autres roms 533
total fiscalité 1377 euros 50 2 et
autres rames 2222 euros 0,8 soit un
différentiel de 844 euros
52 par hectolitres d'alcool pur c'est
beaucoup de chiffres ça fait un
différentiel non plus le 42 % mais de
38%
bon donc je rappelle on passerait donc à
ce qui se fait aujourd'hui 1200 64 euros
à 1377 52 pour les autres roms
aujourd'hui au vert 2012 l'ancien régime
2196 on passerait à 2222 faut-il avoit
que tout ça soit agréé par bruxelles les
simulations effectuées conduisent à un
coût de ce dispositif à hauteur de 103
millions d'euros et non plus 111
millions dans le régime actuel
c'est bien supérieur bien entendu au
régime de 2011 dans lequel la vente
office casser le vert 66 millions bon
vous avez dans quelles conditions cette
affaire a été fait
un peu avant une échéance importante moi
j'étais parlementaire à l'époque on nous
avait dit tout est balisé
pas de problème on peut y aller réalité
balisés et donc aujourd'hui j'espère que
monsieur almunia ne comprendra il nous a
très bien reçus et a fait n'a pas donné
de garanties sur mais a compris un petit
peu l'urgence qu'il y à corriger tout
cela le régime que l'on a on est on est
en train de le notifier entre
aujourd'hui et le 31 enfin entre le 1er
janvier 2013 et le 31 décembre 2013 qui
date actuelle bon pour le saas et pour
corriger si j'ose dire les erreurs du
passé et maintenant il ya le post 2013
puisque le régime prend fin en 2013
il nous faut donc procéder nouvelles
notifications pour la période 2014 2020
sur la base des modifications proposées
pour le régime actuel celui que je viens
de vous les contenus le calendrier
d'adoption des lignes directrices pour
les aides à finalité régionale est
essentielle aux chaussures et que la
décision de la commission sera adopté
avant la fin de cette année voilà le
régime fiscal du rhum traditionnel étant
appliqué au moment de la mise à la
consommation
il ne peut être envisagé de mécanismes
rétroactif au car la décision serait
connue seulement 2004 ça veut dire qu'il
faut faire vite
voilà en quelques mots ce que je vous
dis très rapidement sur les négociations
engagées avec sept à bruxelles je sais
plus ce que j'ai encore fourni puisqu'il
mais il ya un travail qui est en cours
et donc
j'espère avoir une réponse le plus
rapidement possible en fait je dirais
que c'est peut-être vous le savez est
nécessaire parce que nous permet de
faire face à la concurrence j'ai dit les
aide accrue pour les roms des pays tiers
notamment pour le gouvernement américain
mais aussi le marché du rhum est devenu
très concurrentiel du fait que le marché
roumain s'est ouvert au maroc notamment
dans la comté ou en colombie union
européenne amérique centrale l'union
européenne et qu'actuellement il y à des
négociations avec le mercosur
tout ça donne sur quoi de compétition et
peut compromettre la productivité de ce
secteur
monsieur le président eh bien merci
chers collègues question il faut noter
aussi que la progression du rhum du
groenland avec deux d'amerique du sud
est très importante sur le marché aux
biens par pour la documentation sur de
notre propre aux hommes qui n'étaient
pas prêts de qualité ses problèmes
d'alcool finalement qui pourrait très
vite il relègue les deux rapporteurs
alors si je comprends bien oui il ya
deux problèmes il ya une des libéralités
curité et adoptée à l'occasion du vote
de la loi du financier la sécurité
sociale et qui n'ont eu quelques erreurs
commises on n'a pas informé bruxelles
finalement ou lui ça en 3h07 ce
contentieux qui vient de cette
décision-là en trois ans dans les
négociations sur le renouvellement du
régime fiscal
c'est bien c'est alors et des choses
c'est que les peuples hauteur des petits
producteurs ont reçu six à l'occasion
quitterait pas ça ici à l'occasion de la
semaine de la culture
ils sont très inquiets surtout les
petits producteurs sont très inquiets
parce que c'est qu'il faut savoir c'est
une activité web sud qui est essentielle
pour l'économie antillaise les trucs
essentiels et 10 trappistes pas mais
elle organise le plus
le territoire de la sorte et et permet
aussi de protéger les sols lacs adrien
s'est elle monte les mornes et si elle
évite les 6 rebonds fait les si les
images du moins des sols etc
donc c'est très important aux d'autant
que c'est une activité qui embauche
beaucoup de victimes indique beaucoup
d'agriculteurs d'une part et beaucoup de
gens qui chantent qui devrait être dans
la transformation de canne à sucre ou en
robe sous nos territoires
seul un vrai alors pour la martinique
vous avez des web plutôt agricole
c'est-à-dire ont fait leurs hommes à
partir du jus de canne essentiellement
alcool par les dents guyane aussi
d'ailleurs mais à la réunion tout comme
en guadeloupe pop c'est peut-être plus
tôt on fait de rome à partir du sous
produit du sucre c'est à dire la part de
la mélasse s'effectuer duo construit
elle n'est pas du lot marie coll et de
trop rome et de loi m tradition le rhum
agricole
il ne peut pas descendre de sa de 43
degrés d'un colon ce qui n'est pas le
cas et les régions du sud et diffusée
durant traditionnelle et non l'europe
que nous recevrons comme en métro en
français et en europe
souvent quand ils reviennent non pas
seulement de chez nous mais avec latine
qui vendent de l'alcool pur que nos
transforme au réduit avec de l'eau et
qui font du front ont fait du rhum à une
floraison de marques doivent qui ne
connaissent pas du tout alors mais ça
paraît de bacardi
mais vous avez des noms de roms qui
n'ont jamais touché la martinique 1 par
exemple et sérum là pour reste
énormément sur le marché parce qu'il est
seulement intervient dans la
consommation au travers de beuvrages du
style cocktail mojito cetera mais partis
beaucoup étaient bien beau de la
pâtisserie et havas discret dans la
cuisine raconte donc c'est une
concurrence très forte très agressive de
avec la team pour nous et elle est ce
qu'elle est elle a ouvert et la passer
des accords de libre échange avec on a
déjà vu ici un an avec des pays
d'amérique latine en particulier
et payant tant pis ça sauve comme a dit
ce ministre morceau beaucoup sur tout
ceci nous met en difficulté sur les
choses qui étaient en difficulté nos
noms ne trouve pas pris conomie et quand
on attaque le rhum et le sucre
c'est l'économie de base même les fautes
mais essentielle fondamentaux de
l'économie antillaise que vous attaquez
et 70 des zones sont monsieur préoccuper
les prix des producteurs de rhum sont
venus nous voir pour dire leur
population et attend de nous qu'on
défend ses choix par défaut
elle cherche aussi nous allons avec le
même régime fiscal nous sommes morts si
on n'a pas résulté scala otages mais bon
ce ministre oui c'est le président et le
rapporteur de ce ministre deux questions
est-ce qu'on peut considérer que les
négociations ont abouti nous attendons
la décision de la commission
et deuxièmement qu'est ce que le cet
éventuel contentieux pourrait agir sur
le renouvellement de la d2 la mesure
je ne peux pas répondre positivement la
négociation n'a pas abouti parce que moi
j'attends la réponse de la commission en
particulier j almunia qui s'occupe
particulièrement même si plusieurs
directions sont impliqués mais je ne
peux pas dire que ensuite elle est tout
à fait ouverte sur le post 2013 après le
nrel j'espère que la proposition qui a
été faite l'équilibré ils l'ont reconnu
ils attendent peut-être que de faire
leur analyse sur la surcompensation
et ton en train d'aider indûment la
filière affiliés peut-elle supporter
sans aide et sans fiscalité appropriée
et
la compétition le président larcher
vient de dire quelque chose c'est sur la
définition du rôle a défini sur la plus
exigeante du roman c'est celle de la
france on en sait même réunira pas dire
quelques années pour revoir la
définition la plus d'existence et celle
de la france les multinationales dont se
sont adaptés et ici à paris on a ouvert
gigantesque bain où on peut consommer au
nom du rhum ou sous le couvert de rome
des boissons qui n'ont de rome que le
nom et ils font la conquête d'une
clientèle jeune
bon et je lis faut il faut il faut
savoir ça par exemple même pour le rhum
enfin même pour leurs maîtres du trial
on ne peut pas faire comme on le fait
bien simple si nous on fait venir la
menace de n'importe où et on fait sur
les quais ont fait une ovation qui
s'amèneront enfin cet interdit de
commercialiser la mélasse c'est la
menace du terroir qui doit servir et
donc là il ya un vrai souci
donc il y as a ensuite l'europe parfois
au nom de la diplomatie commerciale
internationale au nom de mandat qui est
celui de la commission la commission a
un mandat propre de négociations en
matière commerciale
c'est pas le conseil c'est la commission
et bien mes coups sourds et autres
accords bilatéraux avec de grands
ensembles
parfois on oublie qu'il ya du rhum et
robin il faut le dire comme ça et quels
sont les critères
on va voir des parts de marché
amusez-vous dit ça mais quelque part
vous avez progressé
donc ça veut dire quelque part vous
pouvez soutenir et de manière durable la
concurrence même si on se fait grignoter
par d'autres types de rome qui ne
respectent pas la définition
ensuite on est dans un cadre d'un
contingent pour les
les dom en ses 120 mille hectolitres
d'alcool pur
le reste effectivement sur d'autres
segments il y à une compétition et c'est
là on va pas rentrer dans ces
considérations la martinique a fait un
effort de labellisation avec des aoc
comme ça existe pour le vin avec des
cahiers des charges assez rigoureux la
guadeloupe à l'époque j'étais directeur
de chambre d'agriculture donc j'étais
impliqué m'annonce les affaires là ils
ont fait un autre choix avec des
indicateurs géographique avec d'autres
appellations n'est pas contrôlé là ça
coûte plus cher mais il y a la
répression des présupposés de qualité et
ce qui est vrai en guadeloupe aussi de
là mais il faut en permanence s'adapter
en permanence adapter et 6 2 mais compte
tenu du niveau de productivité de la
définition du contingent et des
problèmes de productivité et de
salariale de protection sociale on ne
devait pas avoir cette aide qu'est la
fiscalité que l'on connaît on risque
d'avoir des problèmes par ailleurs et je
finis la rose est rapporteur il y à la
situation des petites scieries et des
planteurs il faut dire aussi que les
planteurs leur situation n'est pas très
enviable
lorsque vous apportez votre came l usine
à sucre vous avez le prix de la cades
mais vous avez aussi le bruit de la
bagasse puisqu'il ya une aide
aujourd'hui doit être de crise ou 16
euros je sais plus à l'époque c'était 13
euros il y avait 10 euros qui a découlé
menteur sauf où les planteurs qui
apporte le cas d'un distillerie donc moi
j'ai vu le président du sydom qui est
d'accord d'ailleurs d'accord avec notre
proposition pour l'europe
donc ça a été fait avec les socio
professionnels
donc il fallait leur soutien sont
d'accord mais lorsqu'on voit les
professionnels qui viennent en disant
oui il faut que les petits distillateur
soient aidés je n'aimerais pas que le
processus de concentration qui est en
train de se faire en martinique et en
guadeloupe et bien se fasse au détriment
des planteurs il faut que nous soyons
très vigilants soula
percussions si je dis est retombée des
dividendes il faut qu'on le dise très
clairement par ailleurs je vais aller
plus loin il y à un processus de
concentration qui se fait entre la
réunion la guadeloupe et la martinique
avec une société qui est une belle
société qui fait du bon travail que je
respecte mais entre saint louis sucre
tereos et la martiniquaise il y a un jeu
d'actionnariat qui fait qu' on a pris
une loi tous ensemble parlement le
gouvernement la présente et vous l'avez
voter sur contre la vie chère et contre
les monopoles faut le dire
aujourd'hui il ya des exclusivités le
vent du sud de gardel en guadeloupe pour
une société qui est un vendeur exclusif
un monopsone doit être compliqué et donc
qui est libre de fixer ses prix et ses
prix de transfert luz il est très
souvent aidées par l'état et par
l'europe donc il ya là une vigilance
accrue à avoir pour la transparence
ensuite on voulait fermer l'usiné à
marseille depuis lors les choses ont
évolué on disait que si cet accord
devait se faire puisque c'est des
discussions donc c'est
un peu confidentiel mais le gouvernement
doit rester vigilants sur ces affaires
là on voulait fermer la seule usine pour
raffiner le sucre de canne
seules qui existent pour la délocaliser
à marseille aujourd'hui il me semble les
assurances que nous avons reçu ça ne se
fera pas
donc tout ça vous voyez tout peut-être
dans tout on parle de wham mais on parle
de sucre on parle de deux procédés et de
process industriels
il faut suivre tout ça l'europe est
extrêmement vigilante sur l'évolution de
tout ça et du sucre et de la façon dont
s'est raffinée et du rhum et des parts
de marché occupée en france mais en
europe et donc c'est sur la base de tout
ça qui vont décider si oui ou non la
fiscalité qui est celle d'aujourd'hui
mais d'être reconduite vérifier qu'il
n'ya pas surcompensation donc disons une
soupe protection et des aides est due à
une filière qui pourrait vivre sans aide
c'est pas à notre sens le cas donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
demandé la reconduction sous un régime
amélioré et nous l'espérons tout aussi
efficace voilà donc on attend
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous avons avec mon collègue
gillot justement abordé tous ces points
ont lors des auditions nous avons
pratiqué en particulier il ya quelques
jours
et la question que vous le posez après
votre exposé si vous avez dit plusieurs
fois il faut justifier les coûts ça va
paraître un point très important par
rapport à l'europe justifie les coûts
parce que nous savons que les coûts de
production ne sont pas les mêmes dans
les départements d'outre-mer qu'ils sont
dans d'autres pays
wazemmes ça c'est un point très à mon
avis très très important et aussi nous
savons que ça représente des milliers
d'emplois et ses milliers d'emplois
aujourd'hui si on veut les sauver
c'est par cette aide fiscale qui me
paraît indispensable et qu'il faut
absolument maintenir
vous avez dit monsieur le ministre c'est
que vous envisagiez de
donc deux traits de faire des
propositions que vous avez faites vous
même jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2013
et après il restera 2014 2020 est-ce que
c'est justement est ce que vous ne
pensez pas que les propositions qu'on
pouvait faire 2013 risque d'être
pérennisé pour 2014 2020
c'est une question que je voulais vous
poser ça m'apparaît important parce que
nous savons que chaque fois le budget
européen
il est pour six ans et que les aides
sont programmés pour les six années
voilà quelques points que je roulais
souligné et je voudrais ajouter le
président larcher le sait bien que nous
sommes tout à fait volontaire pour
déposer une résolution au sénat qui fera
l'objet donc d'un vote à la commission
des affaires européennes délégation
européenne mais aussi à la commission
des finances dans quelques jours est ce
que pour vous c'est un point important
que le sénat se prononce sur ces points
mais tout à fait monsieur le sénateur
avait besoin d'être sur tenet c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a pris la
précaution préalable d'avoir le soutien
fort créé entier des professionnels que
je devrais moi aller au parlement
européen si tenté que le vent venu droit
sur prononcer sur tout ça est que si le
sénat mais l'autre chambre aussi bouffer
se prononcer oui oui le risque que nous
appelons de nos voeux une chance c'est
que précisément ce que nous avons
demandé pour 2013 soit pérennisée sur la
base de ce que je vous ai dit on
supprimait la différenciation en matière
de vignettes on l'adaptera est pour les
petite distillerie l'eau calculant sur
le volume et non pas sur l'hectolitre
d'alcool pur et qu'on maintiendrait un
différentiel à tout prendre à peu près
égales aux 42 % qui existait avant pour
en cours légèrement moindres pour le
budget de l'état
le sens on se serait sans trois bon si
l'europe pouvait nos agréés ça et nous a
prouvé ça ce serait bien et on attend
j'avoue avoir été très bien accueillis
avoir reçu quelques encouragements mais
j'hésite à dire que c'est acquis
monsieur mondial s'est montré très
ouvert et le dit très clairement qu'ils
comprennent se dit prêt à avancer très
rapidement sur ce sur ce dossier là
ouais je pense qu'il faut faire masser
et se coaliser pour faire aboutir
société en social comme l'a dit le
président pour les économies d'autres
maires et en particulier la réunion la
martinique et de la guyane aussi en
général on rejoue bien reçue à bruxelles
s'appelle réponse arrive après un prêt
et s'est passé très vite
ce qu'on attendait mais je vais oublier
de vous donner concurrent nokia qui nous
font la vie dure ce marché au pied et il
y a bien sûr mais il ya pernod ricard
qui a redit la fraîcheur avec leïla qu'à
cuba et c'est un petit peu le cheval de
troie perdu un quartier français est
heureux car c'est le logo que c'est lui
qui est l'essentiel de leurs amis
cubains qui commercialisent tous le rhum
cubain sur un acte mais cetera sur le
territoire au psg était dans d'autres
secteurs une difficulté puisque nous
avons avec nos propres concitoyens
voilà chers collègues sur le rhum pas
d'autres questions
le ministre a très bien que nous avons
passé la troisième question c'est le
problème de ces mois de mai mais oui
c'est récurrentes qui revient tous les
dix ans et d'ailleurs elle ne
reviendrait plus tôt les dix ans comme
la dernière période c'était 2004 2014
bon ça enfin donc au 1er juillet 2014 il
faudra donc d'ici là un nouveau régime
donc ce nouveau régime ne sera pas pour
dix ans je commence par vous dire ça ce
sera pour ces temps surnom la période de
programmation 2014 2020 dont question
qui reviendra je l'espère
selon un cycle suffisant dix ans c'était
un homme
bon rythme un bon cycle là bon c'est
sept ans mais je comprends la nécessité
de la congruence entre la programmation
et les aides qui sont des aides d'état
et donc je peux je peux l'entendre fin
donc ça n'est pas vraiment une critique
chez nous même si j'ai déjà entendu ça
je rappelle quand même quelques
évidences que vous connaissez mais il
est bon de les martelé c'est une
ressource essentielle pour ces
territoires
c'est plus 2 milliards d'euros c'est un
dispositif de soutien important pour les
entreprises de production de ces régions
là ça a contribué au développement au
maintien au développement d'activités de
production est sacrée quoi qu'on en dise
puisque l'europe étaient sceptiques
un nombre significatif d'emplois il
d'emplois pérennes dans les départements
et les régions d'outre-mer
l'évaluation conduite par des cabinets
indépendants à notre demande mais
d'autres régions et autres organismes
consulaires l'ont fait ont conclu
presqu'à l'unanimité qui a pas de
surcompensation et d'effets de rentrer
dans le dispositif actuel de l'emploi de
mer et que cet octroi de mer ne crée pas
de distorsion de concurrence
enfin cet octroi de mer est absolument
nécessaire parce que il ya permanence
des handicaps structurels
c'est dans le l'article 349 du traité
sur le fonctionnement de l'union
européenne
alors oui on nous demandons la
reconduction
selon un régime préservé mais améliorées
et nos principales propositions je vais
directement à sa porte sur les
modifications suivantes sur le champ
d'application de nos trois maires
notamment l'extension du régime d'octroi
de mer à mayotte dès le 1er janvier 2014
cette particularité l'avant nécessité la
prise d'un texte spécifique comme
ailleurs pour couvrir la période du 1er
janvier au 1er juillet 2014 il n'y a pas
de texte
il ya là un vide juridique ce sera
normalement le 1er juillet 2014 mais
comme ça entre en vigueur au 1er janvier
à mayotte le roi droit l'autorisé pour
éviter les élus ont fait sur l'europe
doit l'autoriser donc on a demandé un
acte ou plusieurs actes aux différentes
instances puisque ça dépend de la
commision mais ça dépend aussi du
conseil
donc il faudra double act donc il faudra
le faire deuxième modification portant
sur l'assujettissement et sur l'hérault
de wable par exemple l'exclusion du
champ d'application de la taxe et
entreprises réalisant un chiffre
d'affaires inférieur à un seuil revue à
300000 euros
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe les
entreprises assujetties ce sont celles
qui ont un chiffre d'affaires supérieur
à 559 euros
résultat en martinique vous avez à peu
près 40 mille entreprises en guadeloupe
à peu près un peu plus car en plus une
entreprise il ya 20 476 entreprises
assujetties
il n'ya que 175 qui paye en guadeloupe
martinique et à la réunion
on a un phénomène de même ampleur donc
beaucoup d'entreprises bénéficient de
notre mère notamment dans les excuses
opérations de leurs intrants delon
matières premières mais ne paye pas et
est donc parce que apparemment elles
n'atteignent pas le seuil de 550 euros
donc ce qui est proposé en europe c'est
que les entreprises seraient assujettis
à partir d'un chiffre de 300 mille euros
j'attends d'ailleurs quelques
simulations pour savoir qu'est ce que ça
donnerait comme recettes supplémentaires
pour les communes et pour les régions
et d'ailleurs on aura là avec le
parlement à voir si ça devait être
adopté en l'état que l'affectation de
ces recettes nouvelles
est ce que c'est pour alimenter le
fonctionnement des collectivités section
de fonctionnement ou une partie pourrait
être consacrée aux investissements ce
qui me paraît souhaitable
on voit lancer l'activité pour éviter
des sur uts mans bon gars là choix
politiques à faire troisième
modification proposer des modifications
de taux on va créer un différentiel
temporaire pour les nouvelles
productions vous savez aujourd'hui qui a
3 tôt enfin il ya trois listes
le textile était prié de 2004
s'accompagnait d'une annexe ii d'une
liste en trois catégories disons cela
comme ça
catégorie a avec un différentiel de 10 %
10 points pardon 10 points pour être
apprécié les listes de catégories mais
les produits qui sont dans cette
catégorie là pouvaient être profiter
d'un différentiel de taxation par
rapport aux visions importations de 20%
et les listes c'est de 30%
bon et puis on a eu pendant dix ans
après observation on s'est rendu compte
que pour réviser ses visées compliqué
très compliqué et que pou faire émerger
des productions nouvelles le nombre des
gênes imprévues dans la liste c'est
également compliqué l'europe propose
j'avoue que j'espère que ça fera l'objet
de discussions d'un différentiel de 15
points pour une période limitée pour les
productions nouvelles le temps
nécessaire à la modification de ces
listes quelle que soit la taille de
l'entreprise donc on va reconduire les
listes il faudra avoir produit par
produit c'est là que tout à l'heure en
avant des solutions c'est là qu'on aura
des problèmes avec les directions de la
commission et on va trouver un régime
pour les productions nouvelles
permettent l'émergence de production
nouvelle de produits émergents
d'activité un nouvel quatrième
modification une meilleure flexibilité
de l'encadrement juridique du dispositif
on va tenter d'assouplir les modalités
de révision je les dis de la nex
relatives aux listes de produits pouvant
être exonérés ou taxer à un taux réduit
notification séparer de la liste des
produits concernés à la commission au
titre de la réglementation relative aux
aides d'état ou régime de révision
annuelle de liste des listes cinquième
proposition
autre mesure proposée c'est la
possibilité d'exonérer d'exonérations en
faveur de certaines activités
c'est un peu compliqué les
infrastructures de développement
économique
recherche l'autorisent en fait c'est un
détail mais il est important de le dire
faudra moderniser les systèmes
informatiques de collecte et de
traitement de données par
l'administration fiscale française afin
de fiabiliser le suivi des données
statistiques
je me suis rendu donc là aussi à
bruxelles
j'ai vu le commissaire à la fiscalité
monsieur gym et à qui nous a dit très
franchement ce qu'il en pensait vous
savez la posture de l'europe c'est une
méfiance parce que c'est une entrave à
la libre concurrence et au libre marché
donc ça a été requalifié à l'époque
comme droit de consommation pas un droit
de douane et donc il faut oser
guichetiers qu'il n'y a pas une
surprotection une surcompensation et que
tout ça n'est pas contraire aux échanges
entre les états il a souligné le
caractère ce que nous avons dérogatoire
du régime se fondant sur l'article 349
il estimé lui absolument fondamental de
bien justifier la nécessité du maintien
de ce régime il a également souligné son
souci de veiller à l'absence de toute
finalité protectionnistes et ne se
résume alors invité la france a bien
démontré le caractère proportionné de
l'aide ça veut dire pour chaque produit
des trois listes et d'une éventuelle
liste production nouvelle qui devrait
bénéficier d'un taux réduit de coimères
d'exonération la france doit justifier
de l'existence d'une production locale
qui m'a aidé voire un peu protégés sans
être surcompensée
d'importation significative et justifier
le surcoût de production
la commission a besoin de ces éléments
là j'ai promis de les lui fournir avant
la fin du mois d'avril
bon donc les délais sont contraignants
l'octroi de mer je vous rappelle est
régi par un double encadrement
communautaire une décision du conseil
est une notification décision de la
commission au titre des aides d'état
cela suppose le rétro planning suivant
examen par la dg taxud donc sur la
fiscalité à la fin du premier semestre
notre demande de renouvellement et des
listes actualisées bénéficiant du
différentiel les trois listes à b et c
la proposition législative de la
commission au conseil donc approbation
du collège des commissaires ensuite
saisine pour avis du parlement européen
dans le cadre de l'article 349 chocolat
comme je n'aime pas trop mais oui c'est
bien deux c'est à ce 349 enfin
l'adoption par le conseil de la décision
par un vote à majorité qualifiée et à
partir de septembre 2013 notification du
dispositif d'exonération de coimères
auprès de la dg comp
donc ces quelques mets servis cl mia
c'est la concurrence suspens enfin le
parlement français devra transposer la
décision de lieux dans le droit national
et ça devrait entrer en application le
1er juillet 2014 dont 7 e c'est un deal
est un peu contraint avec l'inattendu
the lady l'exception pour mayotte qui
doit avoir des textes européens et
français pour que ça entre en
application le 1er janvier 2014
il ya un groupe de travail
interministériel qui travaillent qui est
gérée par mon ministère et la dg homme
un tableau comme eux a été fait pour un
peu standardiser le travail les préfets
sont saisis les présidents de région
sont saisis avec de même fait pour
consulter les présidents d'associations
des mères et je les invite tous le 8
avril
je crois que le 19 mars y avait quelque
chose demain aujourd'hui c'est robert
non j'avais tout le monde pour
approfondir la question
donc on va inviter les présidents de
région et les présidents de conseils
généraux les présidents d'associations
des maires je crois les 8 oui la guerre
non mais j'invite tous la guyane a une
acception elle est sûre le conseil
général a bénéficié d'une quote part
d'antoine mer pour ce quelques soucis
d'ailleurs mais compte tenu du poids des
conseils généraux les présidents de
région les présidents de départements
les présidents d'associations des maires
pour approfondir la question parce que
nous tenons à avoir un dialogue
approfondi avec ses élus les élus locaux
et les parlementaires
je demande à faire vite parce que il
faut que pour la mi-avril nous ayons ces
listes et je peux vous dire produit par
produit
c'est un sujet d'ailleurs j'ai fait
parvenir à presque l'ensemble des élus
le l'étude qui a été faite par le
cabinet langrand c'est ça où il ya tous
les produits avec leur production leur
chiffre d'affaires avec quelques
éléments de gestion les importations
leurs parts de marché faut-il les taux
entre taux interne qu externe
faut-il maintenir renforcir baissé je
finis sur une chose on aura un vrai
sujet sur le maximum de taux c'est 30% 3
points pour la liste c est ce qu'on
pourra maintenir 10 20 et 30% sur les
produits nouveaux il propose c'est nous
qui faisons 15% il faut voir est-ce que
donc on peut développer des productions
nouvelles s'ils tentaient
que ces productions nouvelles se trouve
dans un marché compétitif avec une
protection disons un différentiel disons
de 15 points
c'est un sujet que je soumets à votre
sagacité
voilà monsieur le président j'ai fait le
plaisir probation jugé assez compliqué
mais j'ai relègue je soumets ils étaient
les questions sur le code de winch et
qui a donné au ministre concernant
l'octroi de mer à tout à l'heure on a
parlé de de mayotte et le fait qu'à
partir du 1er janvier 2014 je crois que
mayotte bénéficierait de l'octroi de mer
et vous avez dit bon il va y avoir des
recettes importantes quand j'ai entendu
ce que vous aviez donné comme référence
pour la martinique et la guadeloupe
le nombre d'entreprises est relativement
modeste qui participent financièrement
alors le seuil vont éventuellement va
être baissé ce qui peut faire entrer de
nouvelles entreprises
donc est-ce que vous avez une idée pour
mayotte du nombre d'entreprises qui
seront au dessus du seuil du futur seuil
et quel volume cela pourra
potentiellement représenter
j'aurais juste revenir sur un point qu'a
soulevé mon collègue tout à l'heure sur
l'ingénierie est un vrai sujet vont
chacun sait que alors peut-être qu'à
mayotte y avait pas beaucoup
d'ingénierie la preuve c'est de l'état
la part de l'état à la preuve c'est que
et un certain nombre de problèmes et un
certain retard mais nous savons tous
dans le département que l'ingénierie va
être abandonnée de la part de l'état et
que ça va être repris par les
départements donc là aussi il faudra
peut-être qu'à mayotte
ils s'attendent à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
dead comme cela a été demandé de la part
de l'état pour en prendre un générique
mais que ce soit fait par les
collectivités et donc il faut déjà
s'organiser rapidement pour être en
capacité d'absorber une ingénierie
nouvelle donc ça je le dis pour revenir
au point numéro un mais pour le dernier
point le 3 de mer ça m'intéresserait de
savoir quel est le le volume théorique
ou potentiels je n'ai pas encore ces
chiffres même si c'est demandé parce que
tout est à construire
à mayotte qu'elle est quelles seraient
les entreprises qui assujettit donc
trois cent mille euros
il faut voir si ça peut entrer en
application à jouer avant l'heure mais
pour le moment c'est 550 euros
si c'est ça il y aurait quelques
entreprises et ce qui est pourtant au
delà de ce seuil c'est le moule des
implantations plus il y en a plus il ya
sept
c'est un modèle de développement un peu
paradoxal on pousse à celle que je suis
bête zeppo objectivement et et avoir au
maximum des ports d'azur bien sûr si
vous avez votre production locale vous
pouvez les poser
l'europe avait autorisé une exonération
pour dix ans qui arrive à échéance le
1er juillet 2014 et plus vous avez des
importations plus vous avez des recettes
selon les taux donc le volume
d'importation
je n'ai pas les chiffres mais bon on
sait quels sont les opérateurs les
importateurs qui dépasse 550000 euros ça
on sait et le nom de l'entreprise qui
dépasserait les seuils
selon ce qui s'appliquera à mayotte je
ne peux pas encore vous répond j'espère
que d'ici là sûr beaucoup d'indicateurs
à mayotte nous aurons les éléments sur
le chômage
si c'est sur la base de 2011 c'est ça on
aura les derniers c'est 2007
ouais donc on aura un vrai souci là moi
je sais pas ce que les bureaux nous en
donner vous que je suis et devait donc
on en redemande et le chiffrage là on
devrait très rapidement pouvoir revenir
devant vous et vous donner les vrais
chiffres d'ailleurs je propose mes
services mental
sitôt ces chiffres obtenus de vous les
envoyer à la délégation pour que mon
statut y ait là l'occasion ministre je
passe tous cas pas pour couler au
patient qui a demandé puis vous avez
donné le calendrier de renouvellement de
notre ado mer s'ils étaient renouvelés
mais si ce calendrier n'est pas respecté
qu'adviendrait-il à partir de juillet
il faut il le sera je sais ce que parce
que c'est pas la première fois que je
viens devant vous j'ai entendu dans tous
les districts où nous sommes en retard
non ça ça dans les délais là où j'ai un
doute
il faut que les listes de produits avec
l'appréciation des régions mais après
consultation concertation avec les
professionnels nous revienne pour que je
puisse moi les notifier et entrer dans
la négociation
produit par produit ligne par ligne
jeudi sur toute la nomenclature
douanière et ça oui ça prendra un temps
on ira le nombre de froid qu'il faudra à
bruxelles mais nous sommes condamnés
avant régime
là où je pourrais avoir endossé sur
wired sur mayotte il faut moi j'ai des
assurances de plusieurs commissaires
européens qui feront ils ont demandé
déjà les éléments pour prendre les actes
approprié pour mayotte pour nous
permettre à non de légiférer
voilà au camp discussions et il acquis
ou ce qu'on a mis de côté l'idée d'une
tva régionales ce n'est pas ce qui est
discuté sais pas ce qui est sur la table
de la négociation c'est de reconduire le
régime et l'économie générale du régime
donc le préserver mais l'améliorer il y
a une chose que nous n'avons pas mise
dans la discussion même si elle a fait
l'objet de discussions avec vous ce sont
les services ça peut-être d'ailleurs
je revois franco français mais ça pose
le vrai problème organisationnel
même si j'ai demandé à différents
ministères et en particulier le
ministère de l'économie
la législation fiscale à bercy de voir
est ce que le toit de mai qui porte
aujourd'hui sur les billets
peut-il porter sur des services il y à
des entreprises de services qui dépasse
300 millions qu'il avait les cabinets
des bureaux d'études techniques les
architectes et autres experts comptables
et que sais-je encore en informatique
qui dépasseraient largement l'ancien
150000 euros aujourd'hui aux trois cent
mille euros
bon j'avoue que parfois j'ai une
imprécision j'avais demandé à me
vérifier ça les fiscalistes
est ce que ces entreprises bénéficient
des exonérations lorsqu'il nous importe
elle importe des intrants il me semble
qu'ils aient un régime particulier mais
a priori je lui dis oui donc voilà des
entreprises qui ne sont pas un sujet
qu'il ne paye pas mais qui bénéficient
de certains avantages et donc il
faudrait que chacun participe à l'effort
commun donc ce n'est pas ça n'a pas été
transmis dans la proposition française
dans le mémoire qui a été envoyée à
bruxelles
on ne la peine parce que aujourd'hui le
commerce et le service des douanes ce
sont les douanes qui recouvre la pour
les services ce serait les directions
des services fiscaux qui seraient à
l'oeuvre et ça pose quelques problèmes
d'organisation donc le jeu on avancera
je n'ai pas pour autant renoncer à
l'idée on va voir ça pourrait ainsi
permettre d'avoir quelques recettes
supplémentaires quel est le problème
quels effets inflationnistes aujourd'hui
il est difficile vous l'état d'aller
inventé les ressources nouvelles même si
on pense tous à modifier la fiscalité
locale
là il y un gisement il faut voir quel
effet que sur les prix sur la
compétitivité sur le niveau du coût de
la vie donc sur l'inflation
il faudrait quelques simulations ne
semble pas se faire comme ça en revanche
baisser le seuil c'est un surcroît de
recettes nouvelles pour les communes et
les régions et peut-être pour le conseil
général de la guyane si tant est que les
choses restent en l'état j'avoue que
j'ai demandé au président de région
est ce qu'avec ses recettes nouvelles on
peut diminuer le 3 de mer sur les
produits de grande consommation
pas simplement de première nécessité
parce que j'ai reçu quoi j'en suis
convaincue de recettes que tant aidé le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages à préserver
ou voire améliorées pour l'achat des
ménages a baissé un peu parce qu'il y
aura plus de contribuables donc un
volume que les importants voilà savez
c'est un véritable sujet le ministre
assure l'impact de la trop de mer sur le
niveau de vie
niveau 2 des prix au niveau des
parcelles vont revenir mais deuxième
temps sur des niçois sont dits surpris
quand je vous ai dit que nous allons
parler de ses enfants le mais nous avons
quelques cuillères voilà dix ans que
nous sommes huit ans que nous sommes ici
au sénat et nous avons vu quelques
ministres de des outre-mer passer devant
nous on les additionner dans le cadre de
la mission première
ensuite la talqa de du comité de suivi
et chaque fois on a toujours donné des
propos très rassurants très très
rassurant jusqu'au journal habituel et
plaisantant dire que notre système était
pratiquement condamné je ne mets pas
redoutent du tout venant mais ne
cherchez pas me rassure et ça dérange et
vous vous dirigez vous sur ce nom offrir
de toit fluide épaules et dos
véritablement je sais bien que c'est un
sujet qui est ce qu'il ya eu on a
beaucoup dit
je crois que des propos ont été tenus
dans cette assemblée par d autres parler
des gens autorisés à quelque sorte je
vais parler du ministre du ministre nous
on dit l'europe des affaires européennes
qui ont été très disert pupa pour le
moins pas tellement rassurant par une
ovation mettant aujourd'hui il nous
attend sur vous déclare nous convient
parfaitement à nos sens de ce que nous
attendions mais il ne faut pas le dire
pour que qu'on est dans son bain si
c'est ça si nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
avons les garanties dont il était très
important produit si j'avoue que
jusqu'ici sur la question de l'eau de
mer j'étais très très réservée et je
pensais que nous assistions à une
chronique d'une mort annoncée
si vous dites aujourd'hui que c'est pas
la mort aujourd'hui que renault nous
était un locuteur à bruxelles sont de
bonne composition et sont prêts à nous
entendre nous accompagner j'entends et
je note mais cela veut dire que nous
allons nous entendre une autre registre
monsieur le président je voudrais pas
être assurée je voudrais de mon exercice
devant votre table vous rassurer je n'ai
presque dire un bon compte
je suis d'abord un économiste est aussi
un bon connaisseur de de l'état de la
législation
par ailleurs j'ai quelques expériences
politiques et je connais un peu
l'idéologie qui anime bruxelles
donc je suis je viendrai pas là pour
vous dire c'est tout bon
demain y'a pas à discuter si ce n'est
sur deux autres petits surnoms
les choses doivent correspondre à
l'idéologie qui règne à bruxelles par
des entraves au libre-échange et au
marché libre et non faussée c'est une
première chose même si vous êtes
éloignée même si vous avez les 349 du tf
1 e
vous devez d'abord respecter ce principe
cardinal gelé compris et si vous m'avez
bien écouté et compris si jeudi entre
les mots sinon entre les lignes je vous
ai dit que l'exercice qui consisterait à
justifier produit par produit
avec tous les éléments
ce sera pas simple j'ai commencé par
vous dire ce sera pas 10 ans et en
première main deuxièmement on a un
différentiel qui peut aller jusqu'à 30
points l'auras ton
troisièmement les produits nouveaux nous
mêmes on propose 15 points est ce
suffisant pour faire émerger une
production nouvelle la protection des
industries dans l'enfance comme disait
frédéric liste grand économiste allemand
de l'époque
est ce qu'on peut faire ça bon pour vous
dire que je sais que nous devons
justifier la nécessité de la
reconduction du dispositif avec ses
effets on a fait des études pour ça et
on a prouvé que l'octroi de mer est
absolument nécessaire
je serais trop long je vous épanouir
c'est entre 170 et 205 millions d'euros
pas an dud octroyés aux entreprises
ça contribue pour faire 50 % de la
production de la valeur ajoutée produite
dans nos régions
les niveau d'excédent brut
d'exploitation n'apparaissent pas
suffisant pour absorber la disparition
de la différentiel de taxation si ça
devait disparaître les billets bondé
excédent brut d'exploitation ne serait
pas suffisant pour supporter soutenir la
concurrence
on prouve et puis qu'il ya une
corrélation forte entre existantes
l'octroi de mer et le maintien de la
production de câbles et des emplois et
des emplois
la preuve est faite la preuve est
également faite qui a pas su aux
compensations
l'europe ne se satisfait pas de ça parce
que l'europe a fait et nous n'étions pas
encore arrivé aux responsabilités
on avait fait une première étude c'était
avant moi l'europe a répondu ce n'est
pas suffisant donc on a approfondi les
études et moi même j'ai récusée une
première étude
j'ai demandé des compléments qui ont été
données voilà donc ça veut dire la
discussion n'est pas aussi simple que
que l'on croit mais si je dois vous
donner une conclusion cette fois ci je
vous donne mon sentiment personnel
j'espère ne pas me tromper
comment voulez vous que l'europe nous
disent totalement non à 10 mois de
l'échéance il faudra trouver 1 milliard
32 millions chiffres de 2011
comment trouver 1 milliard si on nous
dit non alors les peaux thèse évoquée
tva alors commandant tva cette
disparition de l'autonomie la libre
administration territoriale de
l'autonomie qui figure dans la
constitution d'un club il faut que la
recette représente un montant comme on
disait dans sa déterminant et je
n'oublie jamais la discussion lorsqu'on
a révisé la constitution alors ça veut
dire moi je suis confiant mais il faudra
justifier
produit par produit d'un différentiel de
taxation nécessaires à l'existence de
des produits en cause très bien tout le
monde et c'est en bonne voie mais pas
comme ça je comprendrais pas contredit
donc si vous faites des résolutions vont
se montrer l'importance que ce
dispositif à vos yeux
tout ça est de nature à nous aider mais
très bien sûr mais attendu jeudi
castillon rebih jacques parizeau le
ministre mais c'est mon inquiétude un
qui fait qui me fait poser cette
question que je pose réussi pour la
défisc est-ce que la stratégie est
partagée par l'ensemble du gouvernement
les arbitrages lorsqu'il ya désaccord
entre entre le ministère n'était pas
très originaux antoine mer aucun souci
il ya là une unanimité forte d'accorder
d'une humilité fonctionnant au soir
position et celle du président de la
république après figurant dans ses
engagements
ces trains engagement pour les outre-mer
à tout faire pour maintenir voire
renforcer l'emploi mieux donc la ligne
et l'objectif est fixé au plus haut
niveau sur la défisc ont peu mon allié
sur la défisc ont faussé recours et des
religions et là aussi il ya eu un
arbitrage correspondance que le
président de la république avait dit
pendant sa campagne qu'il préservera
voix il renforcera l'attractivité
fiscale
de nos territoires de nos régions ça a
été fait ça a été fait alors que nous
sommes en pleine crise des finances
publiques
il ya eu un arbitrage plus favorable que
les trois ministères prioriser à savoir
la justice l'éducation et la sécurité de
l'intérieur
le budget de la mission outre-mer a
augmenté plus qu'aucun autre budget
aujourd'hui il ya gel il ya un surge l
ont fait en sorte qu'il y ait moins
j'allais surgir dans cette mission là
pour tout j'ai gardé un différentiel
j'avais dire favorables bon c'est pas
notre faute si des parlementaires ont
fait jouer leur pouvoir de déférer des
actes législatifs
ça a été censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel dans une part
essentielle de 6 jeudi de l'efficacité
du dispositif à savoir la part variable
des 4% maintenant donc il ya une
réflexion engagée là aussi conformer à
double arbitres à celle du président de
la république qu'il a réitérée dans ses
voeux adressés aux outre mer et celle du
premier ministre qui a dit que pas un
euro ne manquera aux outre-mer voilà
pour cette audition de victorin lurel si
vous souhaitez la revoir elle est
disponible en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne fin
de journée à tous